But if you pick up the Bible
in the complete Bible, the word trinity
is not mentioned anywhere.
If you read this big encyclopedia, it is
more than twice the size of the Quran.
Actually, no, this is in small writing.
This is along with Arabic and English
and commentary. The Bible actually is
twice the size, more than twice the size
of the glorious Quran. Nowhere will you
find the word trinity. Nowhere. The
closest verse that any Christian can
come to regarding the concept of trinity
is from the first epistle of John
chapter number 5 verse number 7 which
says for there are three that bear
record in heaven. The father the word
and the holy ghost. And these three are
one.
The closest verse reginity first epistle
of John chapter 5:7. And if you read the
revised standard version,
this is the King James version which I
was showing which is the most popular.
This is the revised standard version.
Brother want to know which version. I'm
even answering you two in one. I'm
trying my level best in 5 minutes time.
RSV revised standard version. A new
version. Version means
the authentic source differs and the
Christian boasts of 24,000 manuscripts
of the Bible but no two identical.
This is the new kingdom version which
pastor refers to. This is the dway
version which has 73 books. They have
thrown out seven books out of this which
the Catholics refer to as a fabrication.
Who has done that? The Protestants
pastor's Bible is the new kingdom
version has only 66 books. It's a
different Bible. There are various
Bibles various in IRF we have more than
25 different version more than 200
different types of Bible. You can come
and refer to IRF. Coming back to your
question in the revised standard version
which has been revised by TU scholars of
the highest eminence backed by 50
different Christian corporate
denominations.
They said that the King James version
has got grave defects. And when they
revised this, they have thrown this
verse which is the closest resembles to
trinity first epistle of John 5 verse
number 7 as a fabrication as a
concoction as interpolation.
They thrown it out. Who? Not Muslims,
not Hindus. 32 Christian scholars of the
highest eminence backed by 50 different
nomination. They've thrown this verse
which is the closest resemblance trinity
as a fabrication. The word trinity
doesn't exist.
Jesus Christ peace before never claimed
divinity as I mentioned earlier. And in
the catechism of the church they say the
father is a person, the son is a person
and the holy spirit is a person. But
there aren't three persons. They are one
person. Person person but not three
person. One person. What is this? 1 + 1
+ 1 is three. But the Christian says one
and if you ask a Christian that when we
think about the father what is the
mental picture you draw and a Christian
he draws the mental picture like
almighty God like Santa Claus sitting in
heaven with the earth as foottools. Many
says the word or the son of Jesus peace
be upon him somewhat like Jeffrey Hunter
in the movie King of Kings. Jeffrey
Hunter blonde hair
white doesn't look like a Jew he doesn't
apose but like Jeffrey Hunter and when
they speak about the spirit something
like a dove that came when John the
Baptist was baptizing or like the smoke
at the feast of Pentecost
three different picture but when you ask
the Christian how many pictures do you
see he tells you one however much you
try you can never impose these three
picture as one but when you ask them how
many scriptures they say one they're
lying to you because 1 + 1 + 1 is three
it is not one and they give the example
that see the concept of trinity is very
difficult to understand a person can be
a father can be a brother and can be a
businessman at the same time so why
can't almighty god be father son and
holy ghost I said fine let's analyze the
example suppose there's a person who's a
father and a brother and a businessman
suppose the sister goes and says
something to the
a secret but naturally even the father
and that person will know it even the
businessman will know but if you read
the Bible from the gospel of Mark
chapter number 13:32 it says Jesus peace
be upon him says THAT OF THAT DAY OF
THAT HOUR KNOWETH no man knoweth no
angel not even the son but the father in
heaven that means of the day of judgment
even Jesus sky doesn't know even the
angel doesn't know even the spirit
doesn't know only almighty god knows
that means they aren't three in one they
and three in one.
The trinity is the concept which is
illogical. How much you try, you cannot
superimpose. Suppose they say that JS
Christ peace be upon if I agree with him
died on the cross. Do you mean that even
God died on the cross?
[applause]
We would uh request as we are allowing
the questioners to ask any odd question
he wants to ask. We would request them
to bear with whatever answer is given by
the speakers on my right left pastor
Rochnney and Dr. Zakir whether you like
it or not they have a right to answer in
the manner they would like to. Even if
they refuse to answer
if they refuse to present any answer
they have a full right for it. That is
the decision. Even if they don't answer
they have a full right for not
answering.
Let the whole audience be the judge. You
can discuss the details after the
program. May we have the next question
from the ladies for pastor Rochnney.
Uh pastor
I would I would exhort your patience
please the speakers as well as the
audience.
Uh in the beginning of your talk you
said that uh the evil uh is actually uh
taken out by man himself. It's not given
by God. But then according to the theory
of original sin, you say that the man is
born with the sin. So don't you think
it's a contradiction? Can you please
clarify it?
Yeah. Uh, man has inherited not sin but
the nature of sin. Okay. That means man
has inherited
the tendency of sinning. But suppose a
baby dies, what happen? He's innocent.
He'll go straight to heaven. That's what
I believe. Okay. But
the baby is not going to pay for a price
for his daddy and his all that you know
uh because as brother Zakir referred
from the Bible is correct. He's not
responsible for his father's fault as
far as sin and punishment in hell is
concerned. Okay. Uh so nature of sin I
inherited from my father Adam. I sin
because I'm a sinner. understand sinner
means the nature wanting to do wrong
things because of that's a that's what I
inherited okay not the uh so when man
starts sinning himself and it's counted
against him himself so that resolve the
problem of inherit now second thing man
does inherit curses
there is sin and there is curses
Bible indirectly and direct various
places I'm not good time to talk about
it
I don't pay for the sin of my father but
I do inherit curses and you experience
it in your life. My father did a lot of
mess but he died now. Thank God he died
a believer but I suffer today because a
lot of wrong things he did. I inherit
it. No not not my accountability to God
as a sinner. Not my accountability to
God as a sinner. Okay. But he did a lot
of things which is sinful and it happens
that today I am facing a lot of
difficulties in life. It's a curse. It's
a curse. So distinguish between sin and
a curse. Distinguish between sin and a
curse. Curse is a harm as a result of
sin. Is the damage which sin does. Okay.
So there is two things Christ can do to
my life. Number one, he
he obtained forgiveness of sin for me.
So I will not be accountable to God. I
am forgiven my sin. Number two, he
breaks the curse over my life. That's
what the Bible says. Not only he is
having authority on earth to forgive
sins, but he also took my curse upon
himself. He became a curse on my behalf.
The whatever curse was supposed to be
mine, you believe in him, the curses
start breaking from your life. curses
start breaking from your life. So you
distinguish there is sin and there is
curse. Two two different thing. I hope I
have answered properly. I hope at least
I clear your I hope you answer. Yes.
Yes brother. Question for Dr. Zakir.
Uh Dr. Zakir you name.
My name is Richard. I'm a Bible student,
Bible lover and also a fitter by trade.
I'm a technician.
uh you
referred to the Bible speaking about
Jesus saying that they will be like
angels you know spirit body like
spiritualized also you said in the Bible
there is no way mentioned no nowhere
mentioned about the resurrection all
right I will quote just one and many
other this is Matthew 16:21 he says from
that time forth began Jesus to sue unto
his disciples how you must go to
Jerusalem and suffer many things of the
elders and the chief priests and the
scribes and be killed
and be raised again the third day. And
this is the three times and all the
gospels mention it. Not only so the
Bible speak about how he hang on the
cross for 6 hours gave up his ghost
after crying Allah Allah
why of fulfilling the scriptures. Then
we see all the four gospel mention about
his death about his burial and
resurrection. Now you say Jesus cannot
lie with respect to you know the
spiritualizing of the body which is
another topic glorified body is
different a spiritual heavenly body is
different we were better than angels
today we are worse than animals so how
does this come come about to be in fact
I'm not having a discussion I'm a I've
learned by God's love and mercy and I've
got the answers to all your 14 points
and I would like to come to Islamic
Research Foundation and give you these
answers biblically not to win an
argument I would I would love to because
I've got it's true that trinity is not
in the bible it's not this but Jesus
Christ being divine I can let you know
scripturally and even your conscience
even the whole creation will I give you
today I brought many things of the bible
what the original there is a numeric
there is a mathematics in the bible
which can it's a it's a perfect it's a
proof
so uh I've got this things for everyone
can avail of them mathematics proving
scripture question so please Please no
this is my question that how Jesus
Christ mentioned many time that he will
be killed and he will be rising again if
you want another quote I will give in
chapter 20 verse 19 he shall and shall
deliver to the gentiles to be mocked and
scourged and shall crucify him and third
day shall rise again
okay okay just few few just few
no problem
the question is complete
yeah I'm I gave a little I gave you a
little boost so that I can come and
share with you and also to the audience
that you know Bible has all the answers
not the religions
every Sunday we have program at IRF at
you can get the address
every Sunday
every Sunday 10:30 and after the talk is
over you can ask any questions
you can even criticize Quran you can
even I'm just telling you we love it we
love it we like to discuss in friendship
for better understanding
on the Bible
brother you can even ask on the Bible no
problem
not ask I will tell you on the Bible
yes you're most welcome like you told me
just now
brother said he quoted from Gospel of
Matthew and he quoted what he quoted
Jesus said he will die and he will rise.
He said that I agree even we agree. He
will die and he will rise in his second
coming. He will die and he will rise
[applause]
and that resurrection in his second
coming which is mentioned in the Quran
the Bible will be the true resurrection.
True death and true resurrection. What
you are saying that what you put on the
cross he died. You say that from here
say it is but when you check I do know
some people say oh we saw him dead the
soldier says if you read again gospel of
John chapter 19 I'll give you quotation
gospel of John chapter 19:33 we saw him
to be dead like how pastor saw the girl
to be dead he's not expert he said like
a lay man so even the soldier like a lay
man saw him to be dead [applause]
today to testify he's dead doctor
requires telescope he requires the pulse
we have machines like ECG EEG heartbeat
brain and here doctors mistake
here I've got with me so many articles
that a person died for 3 hours and then
he got back to life 3 days several in
South Africa in Philippine ALL THESE
CASES DOCTOR testifying with instrument
with instrument here a soldier lay man
testifies that doesn't mean he's dead
please let me complete the answer then
you can you can go back to the Q and ask
any question or come on Sunday so it was
from here say whether he died or Not
actually I proved 14 POINTS. YOU SAID
YOU CAN ANSWER ALL. YOU HAVEN'T ANSWERED
A SINGLE. He was alive. He was alive. He
was alive. That means he was not
resurrected. He will be resurrected. I
believe every Muslim believes in the
second coming when he comes he will be
resurrected. And the Quran says in surah
maida chapter number 5 verse number 116
117 he says that oh God you be the
witness. I never told them to worship me
as almighty god. But I said worship
Allah
who's my lord and your lord. Jesus
Christ peace be upon him he preached
nothing but what almighty god wanted and
he preached that you should worship only
one god not worship him. And I said that
earlier there is not a single
unequivocal statement. You said there
are statements in the bible saying Jesus
was divine. There's not a single
unequivocal statement in the complete
Bible where Jesus Christ peace be upon
himself says there is God or where he
says worship me. Yes, he will come
again. He will come again for what? The
Quran says in surah nar 4 verse 158 that
Allah subhanana wa ta'ala raised him up
unto himself. He was RAISED UP ALIVE FOR
WHAT? In his second coming he will not
teach anything new. The Quran says surah
maida ch 5 verse number three Islam on
this day have I chosen for you your
religion and chosen for you Islam I have
completed your faith for you nothing new
can be taught he will be coming in the
second coming not to teach anything new
to the Muslims he'll be coming in the
second coming to testify that I never
said you worship me to testify that I
never claimed divinity and as it's
mentioned in the gospels also in the
second coming people will say oh master
oh master did we not do wonders and
miracles in your name So Jesus will tell
them, "Ye men of iniquity, ye sinful
people, you depart from here. I don't
even know you." Who will he tell that?
To Muslims, to Hindus, to Christians.
You're claiming you did miracles in MY
NAME. YOU GET OUT FROM HERE. I DON'T
EVEN KNOW YOU. HE will come in the
second coming. And that time, as the
Quran says in Surah Imran 3:1 185,
every soul shall have a taste of death.
He will die like a human being. And then
inshallah, he'll be resurrected. We are
waiting for that. before the day of
judgment he will surely do that. Hope
that answers the question. [applause]
Yes brother
brother P I have a question for you. For
Muslims there are four to five major
criterias which he has to fulfill to
enter into Jenna. But as given to
understand even from your talks and even
from the neighbors I have heard that for
being a Christian to since Christians
are sinless sinless in the sense they'll
be wiped out they'll be their sins will
be wiped out because of the sins which
are inherit which are taken or by Jesus.
So that means that uh if a person
tonight if he accepts that Christ has
died on the cross for the sins of the
mankind does it mean that his sins past
and future are wiped out and he will
enter into the gates of heaven.
Uh it is written in the Bible if you
believe in Christ of course you believe
in Christ means what he did and what he
taught and you confess him you say it
confess me use your tongue say it and
you receive him genuinely in your heart
uh then your sins are forgiven
and your uh so my my interpretation it
means this your destination is changed
you're not in heaven at that moment
a small question relating to the same
now that means if I read theible I
believe in each and every word of the
Bible. I believe in the death of the
Christ, the crucifixion, the so-called
crucifixion. Then tomorrow I I become a
rapist or I become a terrorist and I go
and killing everyone still I'll be
entering Jenna. You see u
[applause]
if you if you have genuinely believed in
Christ today, you will not be a rapist
tomorrow.
Why not? It is always possible.
[applause and cheering]
Your life will be so changed. See the
thing is
that means you are lying. You did not
receive Jesus.
The thing is there is only one single
statement which shows that you have to
believe in Christ that he died for the
cross that he died on the cross and died
for the sins of the mankind. That is the
only criteria which I know even in your
talk you have said the same thing. If
you believe in Jesus your faith is
interpreted acts of faith according to
the book of James Yak. If your faith is
not counterfeit, not pretending, your
faith will produce things in your life.
But if your faith is a counterfeit just
to uh just to show then your faith will
not produce acts of faith. So suppose
I'm a criminal today. H I believe in
Jesus. I repent. I ask forgiveness of
sins. All these things comes in
believing in Jesus. Repentance means I
have changed. I turned my way. I'm no
more wanting to walk the way of sin.
Then God will help me and I will succeed
not following that old way of living. My
life is changed. Now I may commit
mistakes
that doesn't mean I have abandoned the
faith. A small baby he loves his daddy.
Still occasionally he disobey daddy.
There is a level of disobedience. Okay.
There's a level of disobedience and
there is a level of rejection and
rebellion. So if I summarize it, if I
believe in Jesus today, I repent, ask
God forgiveness, God will break my sins.
If I have genuinely, not just pretending
he knows the secret, I'm saying it in
words or not. And then uh that will
produce things in my life. I I was in
Kuwait. There were many people who are
playing in words in Islam. And one
person he confessed that he is Muslim
and he says
so uh because he wanted to take the
custody of the children from his wife.
Uh so somebody taught him the trick. If
you say that then the Sharia will say
the children belongs to you because your
wife is Christian so therefore they
they'll be in your favor. He did so. He
did so. Then they told the moola who was
a judge, he's just saying he doesn't
mean it. He said, "No, no, no, no. Only
God knows the intentions. He said it. We
heard it. It's a proof he's a Muslim.
Only God knows the intention." That was
you were just playing games and words.
You know, really, he wanted to take
custody of the children. Now, in the
Christian faith, God knows whether you
are genuine or not. If you really
believed in Jesus, God will break sin
over your life. He's done it. Their drug
addicts are broken. Even medical
couldn't help him. But they succeeded.
There's a organization called Teen King
Challenge. They got such a big
percentage of success. Even the best
rehabilitation for drug addicts, they
never succeeded. They only get 2% 3% and
the boys go back and the boys go back
and the boys go back. These people
successfully people for years they broke
with drugs because they're basing on
helping helping the children on the
basis of faith in Christ. Christ is a
practical solution, not just a religion
and nice fancy drawing and some lovely
book with a little bit of colors and all
that. Christ is practical for a daily
living.
Yes. May we have the next question from
the ladies? Dr. Zakir.
Any question for Pastor Rockny? From the
ladies,
if we were accountable to God for our
sins, then why should Jesus be crucified
for us?
See, sorry.
Question is for pastor rocky.
Yes.
Why will God punish Jesus for our sins?
If if we are accountable to our sins,
why should Christ die for us? And the
second part, please repeat the second
part.
Why will God punish Jesus for our sins?
No. See uh uh the the law
exposes sin. That is the law of Moses
before Jesus. He tells you their
standards of God expectation from man.
Basically he tells me how sin and s how
sinful I am. Okay. So really sin has no
remedy as far as human is concerned.
There's no remedy and the law of Moses
is a confirmation. Sin has no remedy.
Whatever you try you'll fall again. Now
Jesus came to break that chain. Okay.
Now I told you at my talk at the earlier
if some friend of mine die for my sin
his death has no value in the eyes of
God because he is only accounted for
himself. But Christ is very unique.
Christ is a man who is not worthy of
death. He is God took flesh on himself
kept his power as God aside. Okay. And
walked as man. Now as far as sin and
judgment on him he's not worthy of
death. Therefore he is a blameless lamb.
No one on this earth is a blameless lamb
in that sense. So therefore his death
was he was very precious and the value
was fit that only this kind of person
dying and there's only one such a person
in history that only then he has that
unique office that he he can take away
my sin. No other person can do that. Uh
so that that is the reason because his
his his being not a committed sin makes
him that blameless acceptable lamb
before God. That that is the reason why
his position is very unique. That's the
reason I hope I hope I made it a little
huh. Okay. his position as sinless
person who is not worthy of death
that makes him the perfect lamb
acceptable to God to receive sin of
people.
So does does that mean that we are not
accountable for our sins if you just
believe in him?
You see I just mentioned to the
gentleman believe is translated into
real acts of faith. There are people who
believe just for some various benefits.
Maybe you'll get some uh some good
salary from some foreign organization.
There are many people do that. But God
knows the secrets. Okay. But I'm saying
if you believe
your life will show. Your life will
show. Okay. Judas the Scariot believed
but really it was not really faith.
Afterwards we saw for the sake of 30
pieces of coins he betrayed his master.
Really from beginning he didn't believe.
That was a counterfeit belief.
Conditional belief. Belief only if
things goes well. Okay. So the book of
James says if you believe your life will
show. Okay. It's not believe. I don't
mean just say words, you know. I mean
say words, you mean it. Okay. I I mean
in a in a sincere heart asking go
acknowledging my helplessness because of
my sin and asking God to forgive me in
the name of his son Jesus. That's the
only way to receive forgiveness of sin.
Whatever you do, there's no other way.
Sorry but uh if you're saying that God
took the flesh and bones
thing you have put your question forward
the pastor has explain we cannot have
another question
for the answer I mean
we will ask please
you can try your
short one line comment
as said by pastor that uh a true
believer in Jesus Christ will never
become a will never become a rapist
tomorrow but if you see the Christians
or or on a whole you see that every
Christian do sin. So that means you're
trying to say that no Christian is a
true believer of Jesus Christ.
[applause]
You are talking about non-believer
Christians. There are many people who
have the labels of being Christians.
There are many people having the labels
of being Christians and they're doing
atrocities and they even the British
when they were in India in my personal
opinion if it hurts you I don't mind I'm
sorry but they misrepresented Christ in
India they were Christian name like if I
my name is Sharma I'll be called Tony
and Joan that if I become a Christian
really the heart is not changed only
external don't these are not
representative of the faith of Jesus
there are there is I said at the earlier
there is believers Christians and there
is traditional Christians they're not
the same these traditional they are just
mix up of religions just having a label
of Christianity that that way you're
looking at the people who are
traditional they're two different things
we Christians we don't worship idols we
don't put photos and bow to it I ask my
pastor we don't know I used to do that
in the past few and I started reading
the Bible and the Torah and I stopped
doing that I never knew uh I used to
worship idols I used to pray to the dead
spirits And God has forgiven forbidden
such things. I never knew I was also
called Christians. I was also called
Christians. I I used to pray to to
persons other than the almighty God uh
mediator and mediator of mediator and
mediator of mediator of mediator and all
these things. God only god can forgive
sins. And uh uh you are you are mixing
between a person having a label
Christians and a person who is a
believer Christians. I'm talking about
the Bible Christians. Those who believe
in the Bible, those are dynamic
Christians. Those type of Christian I'm
talking about. Okay. So you you maybe
have seen people who don't believe in
the Bible, they just call Christians.
They may be having some western name or
something.
Now we just allow another three more
questions before we wind up. Those who
are standing, I would request no further
people to come up and queue up because
you would not get a chance. We have one
brother here. We'll allow one more
brother and I think that he's you have
been waiting for a long time. Okay.
We'll allow you the third question
before we close the session. The
management has given us 10 minutes. Uh
so
brother Zaki you were telling that uh in
the Bible somewhere it is written that
when Jesus came back the disciple were
terrified and they were afraid. Why they
afraid when he's not dead?
There was a question that
when Jesus peace goes to the upper room
where the disciples had gathered there,
why were they afraid when he was not
dead? That is the question which I'd
asked during the talk. Why were they
afraid? And the answer is given because
they thought he was the spirit. They
thought he was the spirit.
But he is not dead. You said
that's what I'm telling you. So they did
not know that. But he is dead.
Okay. Come tomorrow if you you die and
you come over here everybody will get
scared and run away from here.
I agree with you. I agree with you.
Suppose if I read in the newspaper that
this person fell from the 10th floor.
Yeah.
And you think he's dead. But tomorrow if
he comes I'M GOING TO GET SCARED. BUT
then he tells me when I fell down there
was a lorry of hay going. I didn't die.
So from here say I had heard he had
fallen and he died. But when he comes I
being a doctor examine him. I check his
hand he's alive. SO INITIALLY I'LL BE
AFRAID BUT WHEN I CHECK UP WITH him I'm
not afraid. Similarly initially but the
disciples died. Let me complete the
answer then you can speak. No problem
brother. I'll give you time. You can
come again. You can come to IRF. Let me
complete the answer. They thought the
Bible says gospel of Luke 24:37.
They were afrighted and terrified and
supposed him to be a spirit. Supposed
who says that? Not Dr. Zakinite. Who
says that? Luke. They thought him to be
a spirit. But then he says, "Handle me
and see for a spirit has no flesh and
bones." Then they were overjoyed. First
they were afraid because they thought
you have a spirit. When he PROVED TO
THEM YOU were a spirit, they were
overjoyed. Who says that? Gospel of
Luke. The gospel says that Jesus was
dead
and he was buried.
And then he comes.
You said that brother. You said that. I
don't know.
Brother, you have asked your question.
He given his excuse me the you brother,
you have asked your question. The
speaker has given his response. I think
God has given most of the people here uh
good heart, a good mind and they can
decide for themselves. We are not going
to comment on it. What the decision of
the audience is let them decide for
themselves. That is the basic premise we
had of this friendly
uh discussion so that we come to a
better understanding of each other's
viewpoints and not fight over it. Just
understand each other's viewpoint in its
proper perspective. We have two experts
who know their job. Let them give the
answers. If you know it better, tomorrow
you hire a big hall and maybe invite
someone else and people will come and
hear you. They are happy hearing you
now. Yes, brother. You can carry on with
the answer. So all the statements were
from hearsay. They thought him to be a
spirit because they had heard that he
had died. HEARD FROM HEARSAY. THEY
WEREN'T EYEWITNESSES. WHO SAYS THAT?
Gospel of Mark 14:50. All of them fled
at the most critical juncture of the
life of JSK peace be upon him. They all
forsook and left him. Who says that? The
gospel says that they fled. It was from
here say and he proved to them by
showing his hand that he was not a
spirit. And pastor said and he gave the
reason for salvation. The question two
questions posed earlier and the pastor
said that you have to believe in Jesus
Christ peace be upon him. He has died
for your sins and then after that you
should not sin. I don't get it that if
someone has paid for my sin then what is
the problem in me doing sin?
If someone tells me go to a restaurant
dilli darbar I've PAID FOR YOUR BILLS
EAT AS MUCH AS YOU want and then says
don't have chicken I say why you have
paid FOR MY BILL WHY NOT HAVE CHICKEN
don't have mutton I say why that mean
you told me a lie when you told me that
you paid for everything whatever you
have eat as much as you want for your
full life now why are you telling me
don't have chicken don't have mutton
that mean a lie so if Jesus Christ peace
be upon him paid for our sins then
what's What is the problem in us raping?
What is the problem in us robbing? So
this logic if you understand it doesn't
go into the logical mind of a person.
Hope that answers the question.
[applause]
Yes brother, that's the second last
question for pastor.
My question to Mr. Rrooki as you uh know
that every country have his uh criminal
law and anyone who is doing wrong thing
is going to be punished according to the
criminal law of the country
and even even though if you take up
newspaper you will see a thousands of
murders and rapes and lot of things are
going on in the world. Suppose as you
said earlier in your speech in the in
the beginning that Jesus was already
crucified he was not crucified for his
sins but he was crucified for the sins
of human being for the sins of
Christian. If we believe that Jesus was
crucified for all Christians then what
is going to be the situation of the
world?
Yeah. Shall I complete?
Yeah. uh it is uh written that Jesus
died for the sins of the whole world
that anyone who believes in him will
have the gift of salvation that so
potentially it is for you and for
everybody then who is going to going to
the hand handle the situation after that
if everybody starts believing that yes
uh and I I can kill you right now here
uh and I can tell tomorrow into the
court that Mr. Jesus is crucified for my
sins and you cannot testify me. Huh?
Then can you write on the paper that he
this guy should not be testified as Mr.
Jesus is already crucified for him.
[applause]
Um I have answered this question earlier
in the book of James in Hindi in Yakub
says if you really believed you will not
kill me you will not kill me.
You write it and give that if Mr. Ar is
killing today here. Huh? And he should
not be testified tomorrow in the court
of the law of the Indian constitution.
Yes.
Can you give me writing now?
Just a minute. Uh
uh
I will be believe tomorrow that Mr. was
Jesus was crucified. I will believe
tomorrow and I will be a perfect
Christian.
See there are two things in sin. As I
said there is sin and there's damage of
sin. Okay. There there is sin itself. A
simple thing I can tell you. See, you
are you are a believer. You are a
believer. A perfect believer as a
Christian. Huh?
Today morning I told my daughter I I
want to know each and every
table from 1 to 20. You read it and I
will I will listen in the evening just
to keep me happy. She learned everything
she kept in mind and repeated in the
evening. Mr. Zaki is not a Christian.
He's a Muslim. But he can quote each and
every verse from your Bible. Any Bible.
Huh? And you are a believer. You say I'm
a believer. I'm this and that. I'm I
love Christ. But you cannot quote a
single line from the Bible. [applause]
Brother,
you have to put [applause]
should I answer? I would
I would request you to maintain
patience. You just have to put forward
your question rather than passing
comments on what the speaker knows or
doesn't know. That is his right. What he
knows or doesn't know. You have to just
put forward your question and await an
answer.
I mentioned there is sin, there is sin
and there is result of sin. Okay. Now
for example I uh a poor man who just
survived by little food. I'm a thief. I
rob his food and he dies. He got no food
to eat. Okay. Sometime back, sometime
later, some faithful God's servant come
and tell me, you are a thief and you
should not do that. Then I realize I've
done a horrible thing which cannot be
repaired. There's a man died because of
my robbing. But he reforms me. I ask
Jesus to forgive me my sins. And then my
destiny is changed. My destiny is
changed. That is true. That's a fact.
It's a promise in the Bible. It is God's
word. But can I repair the damage? I
have killed a man. I denied him his
food. Answer is no. Then the police will
catch me and according to the law of the
country, I may have to be hungry because
of that. Yes, I I have to bear the
consequences of the harm I did. But I
but my soul is saved because my destiny
is changed. God has wiped my sin from
his presence. But there is a a damage I
caused uh which is so serious and there
is a a price for it in this earth. So
many sins they're so serious I cannot
repair it even after becoming a
Christian. There is another situation I
do a minor thing. Let's say I cheat Saji
uh and then tomorrow God convicts me. I
ask him forgiveness. God I'm sorry for
my sin. I have cheated Saji. Uh Saji
take your pen back. I have cheated you
that day. That's a minor sin where I can
restitute. It is possible to restitute.
But the case where a man died because of
my being a horrible person earlier
cannot be restituted and there is a law
in the country and I have to bear the
consequences of that. So there is the
sin and there is the damage. Not all
damage can be repaired. For example, if
I am alcoholic very heavy drinker all my
youth was spent in drinking at the old
age some faithful servant of God comes
and tell me ask God forgiveness. I ask
for forgiveness in the name of Jesus. I
receive a free gift of salvation free of
charge. I haven't worked for it. God
changed my destiny. But what happened
during all my youth, I have been
drinking beer and my uh liver
developed fibroid.
And then slowly slowly I waste and die
because of that. The damage of sin all
my life has damaged my life. But thank
God my soul is saved. See I this is the
this is the damage of sin I have done
all these years but my soul is saved
because I ask forgiveness. It's a free
gift. It's a free gift. God take the
justice that I deserve out of me and put
it on Jesus. That is the strange the
strange exchange that Jesus takes it
from you and put it on himself. Nobody
is willing to can do that. I hope I
answered it.
I'm not certified. Yes.
Yes. Yes, brother. This would be the
last question for the evening. We would
request the audience to be seated after
the answer for another one or two
minutes. Bear with us for a few minutes
more. Yes, brother. My name is uh Sunday
Matthew. I'm a manower consultant. Name
of my company is Sigma Manpower and
Marketing Private Limited. Well, uh the
question um to Dr. Sah nayagis or the
debate subject what we have today is was
Christ really crucified
asking a counter question is not the
answer for the question it's a simple
logical theory the subject of today is
not whether Jesus has resurrected or not
that subject when you are dealing it on
the problem the evidence for
resurrection which we can find out only
from the Bible and It is a belief of the
Christians and as you mentioned you are
not believing in uh you are not
believing uh Bible is a word of God and
then you are taking the quotation from
Bible and proving that and proving that
resurrection I is not taking place and
then saying that is why the
crucification is not taking place is a
good logic but when we approaching the
subject I personally believe it is not
right. One another point uh yeah the
same question it's a continuation but
one more point on that um now it is a
historical fact the crucification or
death of Christ is a historical fact
where the historians has written it on
that a Jewish historian called Josephus
has written about uh a about the uh
about the crucifixion of Christ and it
was not a secret in a rally uh people
has been tortured him and crucified it
on that then what happened to Christ if
Christ has not died whether he has
hidden somewhere else it his body has
taken down from the cross and it has
been laid down there were people
witnessing it on that but how can you
deny it on this and the last
continuation because I'm the last person
to question it you can ask a new
question no three question you have
already asked I think question you can
ask no problem ask one more chance
you'll give
brother
yeah last chance
we We will answer his question.
We will just let him answer the three
questions. In fact, the management has
put a limitation.
Let him answer the three questions if
time permits and the management permits.
We might come
to answer a comment.
Brother, brother, brother. This is a
question and answer time.
You are allowed to ask only a question,
not pass a comment. You can come to the
IRF, call him to your place, whatever
you'll agree to. Do that after the
program is over. I can't allow it now.
Please
a comment
please.
I cannot allow you now. May we have the
answers to the questions already posed.
The brother posed four question. He said
the topic was was Christ really
crucified and opposed the question was
he resurrected and then he said because
resurrected he was not resurrected
therefore he's not crucified. You're
going in the opposite way. What I was
trying to do is kill two birds with one
stone. I do not have another debate
whether Christ was resurrected or not.
Two birds with one stone. IF HE DID NOT
DIE, he was not crucified. IF HE DID NOT
DIE, HE was not resurrected. Two birds
with one stone. So even if you remove
the word resurrection, yet the argument
remain the same. And you can have the
video later on when it's released. First
I said if a person doesn't die, he's not
crucified. And then I went to say that
for resurrection also death is required.
So I'm killing two birds with one stone
trying to prove that Jesus Christ peace
be upon did not die. If he did not die,
he was not crucified. If he did not die,
how can he be resurrected? I'm killing
two birds with one stone. But I'm
sticking to the topic. I'm not going
away from the topic because both these
things are important. According to Paul
1 Corinthian 15:E1 14 that and if Christ
did not die and rise, our preaching is
vain and your faith is vain. So I'm
killing two birds with one stone. You
can refer to the question. You ask the
next question that historians have said
Jewish historian that he has been
crucified. Do you know brother how much
of material has been written on Christ
has been really crucified? Double the
material is written that he WAS NOT
CRUCIFIED. HISTORICAL ACCORDS we can
come to IRISH [applause]
I can quote venturi ventur philosophies.
He said St. Paul I can give you how many
names you can give? I'll give you double
the quantity names of historians, not
Muslims, Christians, non-Muslims, I'll
give their names. The fourth question,
if Jesus Christ, peace be upon him, did
not die, what happened to him? Was he
put below the earth etc. I feel you
didn't hear my talk
and my rebuttal and my question answer.
I made it very clear in chapter 4 verse
157.
They didn't kill him. Neither did they
crucify him. It was only made to appear.
So next verse surah Nisa 4:158 it says
that Allah subhanana wa ta'ala raised
him up alive. I've said that that he was
raised up alive unto himself. Allah
subhanana wa ta'ala raised Jesus Christ
peace be upon him unto himself. It is
even mentioned surah Imran chapter
number 3 verse number 55 that he was
raised up alive and he'll be coming
again in the second coming. So all your
four questions have been answered and
the pastor said what I have got from his
answer which he gave earlier. Every time
I meet a Christian I get a new answer.
He said that certain damages cannot be
repaired. He said that it is on video.
That means for certain sins Jesus Christ
cannot pay. [applause]
What I get to understand
what I get to understand every time I
meet a new Christian I get a new
ideology of Christianity that for small
sins Christ has paid peace be upon him
for big sins he has not paid that's what
I understand that's what I understand
yes brother you had some comment brother
just you can just ask your question
instead of a comment because one in his
5 minutes there are yet two 3 minutes
left I will allow him to answer only in
the 3 minutes not to 5 minutes yes
brother quickly your question quickly
the answer within 3 minute. Okay. Uh now
the entire argument which you have given
based on the biblical quotings and when
actually the subject was the Christ has
really crucified what you have there to
talk from the Quran. Quran when you are
saying if you are saying a statement and
if you are repeating a statement that's
not an argument. I say there is a god
and I say 20 time there is a god that's
not an argument. Argument require
subsequent support. So what support you
can give from Quran for Christ has not
crucified other than that of the
statement. I expect a replay not to get
the clap from the audience but for an a
non-M Muslim can understand and getting
of a clap is simple but making others
understanding is difficult. So not to
get a clap but to make to me I
understand on that asked a very good
question that if you make a statement it
doesn't become a fact it should be from
authentic source and I do agree if I
quote from the Quran Jesus Christ peace
be upon him was NOT CRUCIFIED YOU NEED
NOT AGREE WHY because according to you
the Quran is not authentic I've got no
problem but for the Muslims it's
authentic they say it's THE WORD OF GOD
FOR THEM IT IS SUFFICIENT proof if I say
anything from the Bible what happened to
Christ. It may not be proof for the
Muslims BUT FOR THE CHRISTIANS it will
be. Do you agree the Bible to be the
word of God or not? You agree? Good. He
agrees. SO PROOF FROM THE BIBLE Jesus
Christ was not crucified. SO WHY DO YOU
REQUIRE HISTORICAL PROOF? Do you think
historical proof is superior to God's
word? Don't clap. Don't clap, please. He
doesn't want you to clap. He wants to
understand.
It's a matter of faith. It's a matter of
the proof should be I mean it's a matter
of faith. That's why it was required.
That's right. I'm saying as long as you
are convinced. I'm not here to convince
the non-Christians. To convince the
non-Christian, I can give historical
proof. We can have a new debate. If a
non-Christian comes and tells me
the Bible from here and there is not a
proof
who quoted
wrong. I mean the quotation which you
have quoted is right. But it has picked
up from a wrong place which has
mentioned on a wrong incident.
Brother has that allegation. I have
quoted rightly but out OF CONTEXT. YOU
GIVE THE CONTEXT.
No problem. IT'S A FRIENDLY DISCUSSION
FOR UNDERSTANDING. COME TO IRS. You give
the CONTEXT AND WE'LL DISCUSS IT. You're
most welcome. I'll come and meet you
then.
[applause]
Uh we thank God
Almighty for making this evening of
understanding
each other's viewpoints between two
major faiths of this world possible for
all of us present here. We would like to
thank the India Gospel Mission and the
Islamic Research Foundation for getting
together to organize this program. I
would like to personally thank Pastor
Rockny, Pastor Saji, Dr. Zakir and all
of us present here today, Jazakam Kiran.
May God reward all of you.
Living [music] empty [singing] lives.
[bell]